il est né comme moi le en mars en mars
mais lui 94 pour un petit peu avant donc
on a 20 ans d'écart
c'est horrible bling bling à monstre à
Dubaï tu vas me dire que c'est joli ça
non il est très beau Justin Bieber avant
dans tous les droits de son catalogue
musical donc il a vendu son catalogue
200 millions de dollars donc ça ne va
partir plus à actuellement d'autres
l'avaient fait un bob dylab Bruce
sprinting pardon Shakira 50 Cent mais
souvent sur des gens qui sont plus en
fin de carrière et le répertoire
comprend 290 titres c'est pas rien et il
est là l'un des artistes musicaux de
tous les temps à avoir vendu son
catalogue le plus jeune alors ce qu'il
faut que je vous dise et ça a été
démenti derrière c'est que en réalité
selon mes sources selon les tourneurs
que j'appelle il est en train de se
séparer de sa meuf et il a besoin
d'argent mais comme il y a quelques
années il avait rencontré Dieu je suis
pas sûr vous souvenez la main de
une liaison et non ils se sont postés
tous les deux en train de fêter la vente
du catalogue ils ont fait une grande
fête etc moi je pense plutôt que il y
aurait sûrement un futur scandale qui va
éclater donc il dont il la connaissance
et qui impacte très la vente de ses
musiques etc et qui préfère s'en
débarrasancer son débarrasser avant que
le scandale
dans son cas ça ferait monter encore
plus
peur les gens commencent à me connaître
Matthieu on fait des scores pareil de
leur mot ça veut dire celui qui sait en
hébreu ainsi
merci
[Applaudissements]
un petit peu alerté par les problèmes de
santé très peut-être pas très grave mais
très important qu'il a eu l'année
dernière parce que là si il lui arrive
quoi que ce soit il a été paralysé de la
moitié du visage il a annulé plusieurs
tournées ça a été très compliqué il
aurait pu ne jamais retrouver la
mobilité à 25 ans à 25 ans on se remet
beaucoup de choses moi ce que je vous
dis c'est que déjà il a fait un truc
incroyable il se montre avec sa copine
et il dément aux États-Unis et Hollywood
c'est tous les signes et les papa vous
le disent j'ai appelé valliella et tout
c'est tous les signes en général d'une
séparation et on essaye de la gérer
voilà c'est tout ce que je peux vous
dire
la logique si par exemple il ne se
sépare pas une demande pas non mais
quand tu commences à te montrer beaucoup
c'est que tu sais que ça parle dans ton
dos et tu en fais un peu trop si t'as
rien à prouver tu t'en fous tu laisses
faire beaucoup quand même ensemble etc
sur Instagram
il y a déjà des artistes comme ça qui
ont vendu justement leurs droits
d'auteur ou leur catalogue et qui les
ont récupéré en fait c'était des
sociétés qui leur apportent dans
quelques semaines